[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat le
numerus clausus ce strict système de
sélection qui fixe le nombre d'inscrits
accepté en deuxième année de médecine
sera officiellement déplacer supprimer
pardon dès 2020 emmanuel macron a
confirmé cette mesure la semaine
dernière dans le cadre de la réforme du
système de santé l'accès aux études de
médecine dentaire de pharmacie et de
sages-femmes ne sera plus limité par des
quotas il n'y aura donc plus de concours
sélectif à la fin de la première année
alors cette suppression du numerus
clausus at elle est elle nécessaire
c'est le débat du jour avec nous en
plateau ce soir pour en parler
pierre levy médecin généraliste membre
du conseil de l'ordre des médecins des
yvelines et puis ça y est le chili
président de l'unef à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation avant d'en
parler je vous propose de voir ce qu'on
pense ce que pensent de cette réforme
les étudiants justement en médecine de
la faculté de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines dans ce micro trottoir ils
vont forcément faire d'autres mesures
sur le sujet ils peuvent pas laisser
passer autant d'étudiants en médecine
pour juste pour supprimer numéro sociaux
s'ils vont devoir soit est allé en
faisant plusieurs petits concours qu'un
seul de gros en première année où ans et
en 5e que de laisser passer autant de
monde
je pense qu'il faut quand même qu'ils
aient une sélection d'une manière ou
d'une autre mais en fait ce que je
pensais que le numerus clausus était pas
vraiment la bonne manière de
sélectionner gens
c'est surtout le fait de travailler ceux
qui travaillaient plus mais pas ceux qui
pensaient le plus juste pourquoi pas
mais pour mettre quoi si c'est pour être
une section sur dix ans non et en même
temps le négoce que ça ces failles oui
mais parce qu'il serait bien c'est qu'on
est ce qui serait vraiment bien c'est
pour nous demain d'autres amis en fait
enfin loupé son rêve parce qu'on a coché
dit mc à la place de l'utmb non enfin
c'est pour vous c'est un millièmes de
point
mais parfois c'est une place et sept aps
la salle peut être crucial il a des avis
mitigés chez des étudiants tous y voit
du bon et du mauvais finalement et
surtout il ya des inquiétudes sur une
éventuelle échéance ce retardé de
l'échec
je me permet aussi de corriger je me
suis trompé sur votre nom et c'est moi
de votre nom c'est nein chili
excusez moi donc voilà je vais commencer
une première question avec des chiffres
en fait donc le numerus clausus à
l'échelle nationale c'est 7700 place à
peu près l'année dernière en médecine
pour 58 mille étudiants en première
année commune aux études de santé
alors forcément près de 80% d'échec au
concours de fin de première année
est-ce qu'il était nécessaire de
supprimer ce nu ce numerus clausus je
peux commencer par vous appliquez le sur
le diagnostic tout le monde est d'accord
la sélection est telle qu'elle se fait
actuellement en paces en première année
est totalement aberrante
mais de là à supprimer le numerus
clausus
c'est une aberration parce que comme
diraient certains
à partir du moment où il ya du riz a flu
est ce qui est présenté actuellement est
très flou hier loup et le problème est
de savoir où on va mettre le curseur
pour la sélection parce qu'il devra y
avoir une sélection d'un moment c'est
d'une aberration parce que il faut une
sélection un moment donné pourquoi c'est
une aberration de supprimer le
le supprimer complètement parce que lee
aura pas des structures d'accueil de
formation dans des universités qui sont
déjà en flux tendu actuellement et il
faut que au contraire on élargissent le
numerus clausus on n'est pas obligé de
me supprimer et surtout qu'on repense le
cursus des études médicales
c'est éventuellement peut discuter sur
une rencontre le continu des
connaissances mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire des étudiants en maïeutique enfin
pour les sages-femmes en pharmacie et
ses rations fait un tronc commun de
trois ans qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire au
bout des trois ans quand ils se trouvent
c'est donc en cours on va en parler le
gouvernement parle de réorganisation
d'ici noël
donc si je comprends bien vous êtes pour
une augmentation du numerus clausus mais
pas sa suppression alors les syndicats
étudiants qu'en dit il nous est
favorable la suppression de ce numerus
clausus pourquoi
de deux choses d'abord qu'on a un bon
contact y avait une pénurie du personnel
médical une pénurie de médecins on a
connaît les fameux phénomène déserts
médicaux en france et donc il faut y
répondre et c'était un peu
d'incohérences de garder une limitation
du nombre de personnes pouvant continuer
ses études de médecine
alors que pourtant une grande partie des
étudiants en première année d'études de
santé avait le niveau pour continuer par
exemple un chiffre à versailles saint
quentin est la première personne recalés
au concours de paces à 13 sur 20 de
moyenne alors que la première à 14 ce
qui montre que des personnes qui ont
largement les caps et de continuer été
rejetée à cause de ce numéro sur lotus
oui il faut le supprimer
par contre faut voir comment c'est fait
ça rien de décaler la sélection de trois
ans plus tard est effectivement aussi
augmenter les moyens déjà aujourd'hui on
pressent qu'on ait de nombreuses
difficultés
ça sert à rien de faire pousser la plus
loin d'accord donc je rebondis sur la
nature en fête de ce concours est ce que
ce ne serait pas celle qui prend forme
d'un qcm je crois on a entendu dans le
micro trottoir une des personnes qui
parlent de oui on on arrivait à un échec
à côte ont accouché b au lieu de 2 c est
ce que c'est
c'est cet aspect là c'est la forme de ce
concours qui poserait peut
éventuellement problème oui la forme du
concours même si le principe même du
concours en lui-même on peut faire une
sélection sur tout autre mode par
exemple en introduisant des c'était des
matières beaucoup plus social en
médecine plus que mathématiques sciences
physiques et biochimie et faire en sorte
que les gens soient sélectionnés
réellement sur leur capacité à assumer
plus tard la profession de médecin parce
qu'ils étaient reprochés finalement
assoupi cm si je puis dire c'est que
l'évaluation se fait sur des qualités de
travail de mémoire et pas sur leur
capacité à être des médecins avec des
bons des bons rapports avec les patients
par exemple sur des valeurs plus
humaines
j'imagine la basse et ça se joue autour
d'un concours qui comme le degré zéro de
la pédagogie de l'évaluation c'est à
dire un qcm qui favorise aussi
d'ailleurs des matières extrêmement
scientifique ont fait apprendre des
étudiants beaucoup jose en physique
raisons qui m'ont pas réutiliser plus
tard dans leurs études ou durant leur
profession pareil on mettrait pas en
avant toutes les questions sociales
toutes les les valeurs humaines qui sont
importantes dans ce genre des métiers et
puis au delà du concours tout au long de
l'année ça des conséquences à pouze
étudiants à bachoter comme jamais à
vivre beaucoup de stress un véritable
enfer tout on l'année pour peut-être au
final échoué alors qu'ils avaient la
capacité est de voir ça oriente est donc
passée à côté de l'or est donc supprimé
le numerus clausus mais aussi réfléchir
plus globalement à l'organisation des
examens et penser une pédagogie plus que
si je reprends on ne sait pas ce qu'il
en annonçant il ya une annonce de
suppression de ce numerus clausus mais
quid de la réforme de ce qui sera
annoncé plus tard la ministre je
rappelle de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal indiqué vouloir
diversifier les voies d'accès aux études
de médecine
après cette suppression il y aurait plus
de première année commune en santé ni le
concours à la fin de cette année mais
est ce qu'on sait sur quels critères
seront formés les futurs médecins et
combien sont-ils etc
comment on commencerait rené sûrement
main il n'y a aucune information pour
l'instant donc une information qu'il
faut voir également le problème
essentiel et ça je l'attends c'est les
moyens qu'on va mettre derrière
enfin encore une fois c'est les moyens
financiers logistiques organisationnel
c'est ça l'important
le reste oui alors je voulais revenir
sur une déclaration d'un député public
en marche
olivier ferrand qui disait que le
numerus clausus est une aberration parce
qu'il parlait de la libre circulation
des médecins en europe qui apparemment
est un problème plus que ce concours ne
servira à rien plus que donc en raison
de ces libre circulation les médecins à
des médecins en europe
elle peut pas être figure du coût des
médecins ne veut pas être régulée leur
nombre en france
d'accord avec sa une sur cette
aberration du coup du numerus clausus en
france oui bien sûr mais on ne peut
absolument pas prévoir si en supprimant
le numerus clausus on formera dans
quelle situation va se retrouver dix ans
plus tard c'est pas possible parce que
tous les gens qui seront formés
n'utiliseront pas leur diplôme
on est capable comme le duo les
révérends d'évaluer le nombre de
médecins de l'europe de la communauté
européenne qui viendront à exercer en
france c'est pas parce qu'on va
supprimer le numerus clausus que ça les
empêchera de venir puisque le statut est
beaucoup plus favorable et c'est donc
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à aller vers la
suppression simplement mathématique
c'est le problème du masque aux us c'est
pas un problème mathématique c'est pas
parce qu'on forme on laisse rentrer plus
d'étudiants en médecine qu'on va avoir
plus de médecins dans les déserts
médicaux je le comprends pas nine chili
est-ce que du coup joue en tant que
représentant d'un syndicat vous trouvez
que c'est vous reprochez quaas nuance
clausus est ce que c'est un système
obsolète par exemple bah c'est un
système qui a été créé pour réguler le
nombre de médecins sans qu'aujourd'hui
on ce qu'on compte qu'il y en a pas
c'est donc la faire des choses fonds
serait d'augmenter leur nombre
et oui peut-être sera pas suffisant mais
je pense qu'une première étape le fait
que permettront de la plus d'étudiants
de continuer leurs études et d'avoir un
métier à la fin c'est une première étape
pour remonter nombre de médecins dans le
pays après tout un tas de choses à faire
aujourd'hui effectivement il ya
énormément d'étudiants qui contourne le
système vont étudier à l'étranger il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui un tiers des
nouveaux médecins qui rentre à l'heure
des médecins il prit ont un diplôme de
en dehors de la france à l'étranger ce
qui montre que c'est une aberration qui
n'avait aucune à la cohérence dont des
français qui ont été formés à l'étranger
sully moscow si ça c'est que il mettait
une sélection de fait après un pays
hypocrite de la part de la réplique en
marche parce qu'ils ont mis en place la
section en première année de liberté
mais en général c'est un peu hypocrite
de faire ce genre de choses en tout cas
permettre aux plus grandes de pouvoir
continuer ses études réformes et si tu
te sentais qu'elle soit plus
pluridisciplinaire tout en permettant à
chaque le formation d'avoir ses
spécialités renforcer tout ce qui est de
connaissances en termes de domaine de
sciences sociales sciences humaines
extérieur et aussi augmenter les moyens
à versailles saint quentin pour donner
une idée on a augmenté de 300 le nombre
de places en première année l'année
dernière ce qui est une bonne chose il
faut le saluer se disent a pas été
étudiée de moyens on se retrouve donc à
décision qui depuis le début du mois de
septembre n'ont pas de cours en
présentiel suivent des cours en ligne ce
qui est une catastrophe totale et ce qui
montre qu'à une urgence investir dans
son supérieur donc ce jour parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya du bon et du
pas bon dans ce numerus clausus est ce
que finalement est-ce qu'il faut pas le
supprimer quelle est la solution
vous avez à peu près une minute chacun -
commencerai par dire qu'il faut
l'élargir sans que sucré mais de façon à
ce qui est quand même une sélection et
qui doit se faire quand même
à mon avis le plus tôt possible
simplement pour des problèmes de
reconversion et puis deuxièmement que on
forme des médecins en fonction des
capacités de formation
je prends un exemple pour les
généralistes se développe le stage
auprès du praticien c'est-à-dire leur
cabinet médical
si vous en voyez une flopée d'étudiants
non contrôlés dans les cabinets médicaux
il faut voir derrière le nombre de
médecins maîtres de stage capable de les
accueillir
c'est pas le cas du tout pas du tout
alors qu'elle chérit je vous pose la
même question du coût qu'elles seraient
quelle sera la solution selon vous la
solution c'est supprime une hausse plus
pourquoi me permettre situant qui ont
atteint l'an passé pour vous c'est quoi
il faut supporter on en étudiant le
niveau pour passer dans une super je
vois pas pourquoi il faudrait l'empêcher
de continuer car il a le niveau
il a une voix c'est ça le débat
aujourd'hui investi en assumant
supérieur ça doit se faire dans plein de
filières mehdi compris en médecine est
par contre justement je pense que avoir
une trois années qui soit plus +
réticulaire permettra facilitera le
nombre d'orientations le fait de pouvoir
aller dans d'autres formations si
finalement ce qu'on compte qu'on n'était
pas fait pour
donc c'est par ce genre de voilà en
réformant aussi tu me sentais au delà du
losc aux us qu'on arrivera non seulement
répondre à la pénurie de médecins et
aussi à former un plus grand nombre de
jeunes de notre pays
très bien merci à vous deux vous vouliez
a ajouté qu'il faisait jouer la plus
quelque chose très rapidement c'est
qu'on parle des études médicales mais
cette sélection elle existe dans plein
d'autres dans plein d'autres études
prenais ma tube maths spé
il ya que des cerveaux et pourtant ils
en restent pas mettre sur le bon donc ne
réduisons pas ça un problème
mathématique ya des choses à mettre en
place derrière et pour le juste milieu
c'est pas la suppression c'est pas le
maintien c'est déjà enregistrés pour
vous l'élargissement pour vous la
suppression avec sur la sélection soit
en médecine dans les autres filières
aussi également très bien mon ya
beaucoup de choses à dire on va arrêter
là puisque le temps est compté merci à
vous deux c'est la fin de ce sept huit
débats prochaine émission mercredi
prochain d'ici là vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur tv 78
points communs ou l'application tv 78
merci à tous bonne soirée
[Musique]